there's been more flooding overnight the
water has breached yet another flood
defense and this invader is taking over
this
is the indus highway
it's a
road to nowhere it's completely
submerged in water now and the only way
you can get anywhere is by boat we're
about to join a rescue mission because
of the people that are trapped far out
there
sekanda is desperate his family is stuck
in their home the water suddenly burst
in
[Music]
we have gone through village after
village and every single house is
completely submerged not just the ground
floors but the first and second floors
in the bigger houses
this is incredibly deep water
[Music]
after an hour and a half we finally
reached segunda's home and the rescue
mission is well underway
the children and women are scared
but here too
not everyone wants to leave the family
home
it takes more than three hours to carry
out this rescue it's traumatic and
emotional
bunny
[Music]
and finally on dry ground
yet their ordeal is not over it's only
just begun they have nowhere to sleep
nothing to eat and have lost their
livelihoods in the farms nearby
it's all under water
saima morsin dadu and sin pakistan